sure mean bottom gear likes to think
differently to challenge and to drive
innovation
she's a company founder with a PhD in IT
management she was born in Iran grew up
in Vienna and now lives in Berlin it's a
creative City and a great place to work
on her unusual ideas in a co-working
space she develops new digital
technologies together with startups
[Music]
boy on five-eighths Mia starting
something new isn't hard for me anymore
I actually seem to look for ruptures for
discontinuities maybe that's because I'm
a child of the Diaspora my parents had
to leave their country when I was four
maybe that's so deceide emotionally I'm
driven by curiosity you have to
understand things and the only way to
understand them is by doing them that's
why I do something completely new every
two to three years share means awesome
gears current focus is blockchain a
complex technology that she thinks could
change the world blockchain is a new
kind of digital operating system that
applications can run on it already
underlies the cryptocurrency Bitcoin it
could make banks and insurance companies
redundant in the future blockchain is a
decentralized computer network
containing encrypted data entered by
users online all computers in the
network receive an identical copy which
creates a chain of data records that
allow transactions to be processed they
wanted to send you money today we've
only just met I don't really know you
so I also can't trust you I would only
do it through a central authority like a
bank or provider like PayPal or a credit
card company or a MoneyGram or something
now it's possible to send money directly
to you and I don't need an authority
that's blocking the blockchain protocol
the code and the decentralized network
have a mechanism that means I can trust
you even though I don't know you I know
that the money will go to you and you
can trust that I actually have the
bitcoins I'm sending you it means we
don't need the central authority anymore
instead transactions are checked for
validity with a kind of majority vote
system
and if they're genuine they'll be
carried out automatically Shemin bottom
gear is often in Vienna where she grew
up
she teaches here and advises companies
she's used to people not understanding
her when she talks about the
transformations underway in our new
digital world when we wrote our first
email or surf the web for the first time
we never imagined what other
opportunities the internet would bring
such as social networks in my experience
most people have trouble imagining a
world that's different from the status
quo people think that what I'm saying is
like voodoo
they just can't grasp what I'm talking
about even big companies still have a
lot of catching up to do in terms of
digitalization única is the biggest
insurance company in austria and they've
asked dr. bottom gear for advice for
corporations the central question is
will the new technology be a threat to
their business model or a way to make
money they turn to startups and
blockchain experts for help
what's why I'm finishing the Niemen
giggling huh
two years ago I was going into companies
and giving lectures to explain the
basics now we've progressed to the point
where companies are getting to grips
with the topic they have a rough
overview but as always the Devils in the
details
the Vienna University of Economics and
business has just set up a new Research
Institute for crypto economics and share
means awesome gear as the director
digital currencies blockchain run
governments contracts without lawyers
there are limitless possibilities but
Basham gear also wants the institute to
research the dark sides of blockchain
domestication it's a very powerful
technology and it will spawn further
technologies we can use it as a machine
to promote universal freedom to create a
better decentralized society with less
bureaucracy which will be better suited
to a globalized world if we don't do it
right the very same technology can
become a machine for universal control
to prevent that we have to take all
aspects into account
right now we can only begin to imagine
where these technologies will take us
the more complex our technology the
harder it is to predict what it will
lead to